throughout the years Jim Carrey has
shared this screen with many acting
stars and legends unfortunately some of
them are no longer with us Philip Baker
Hall appeared in both The Truman Show
and Bruce Almighty alongside Jim Carrey
in the former he played one of the
television Executives who helps to
orchestrate the events of Truman's life
while in the latter he played Jack
Baylor Bruce's boss at the news station
outside of car's movies Paul is probably
best known for his appearances in the
likes of Boogie knights in Magnolia RS
that saw him nominated for two Screen
Actors Guild Awards
Paul suffered from empyema brought on by
a childhood bout of pneumonia the
illness severely affected him later on
in his life forcing the actor to limit
filming to short burst to avoid becoming
exhausted on June 12th 2022 LA Times
writer and a close friend of Halls Sam
farmer announced the actor had passed
away at the age of 90 George Seagal had
a decent sized role in the Cable Guy
Port traying Earl Kovac this character
was the father of Matthew Brack's
character Steven who befriends Jim car's
Ernie at the start of the movie zigal is
perhaps most famous for his role is Nick
and who's Afraid of Virginia wolf along
with key appearances in the St
Valentine's Day Massacre The Duchess and
the dirtwater fox and no way to treat a
lady near the end of his career Sagal
moved away from Los Angeles to Sonoma
County in Northern California on March
23rd 2001 his wife Sonia revealed that
he had passed away it was later reported
that the actor and comedian had died as
a result of complications from an
earlier bypass surgery at the age of 87
in Santa Rosa fans of Liar Liar will
remember an Haney as Fletcher Reed's
secretary and personal assistant
a few years prior to that she starred
alongside another comedy Legend Robin
Williams and Mrs Doubtfire portraying
the social worker Mrs selner with her
dead pan sense of humor Haney had a
regular role in the sitcom Mama's Family
and made appearances in the likes of
Cheers Charmed and Kier enthusiasm the
actor also had memorable roles in
Midnight in the Garden of Good and Evil
and the American president Haney died at
her home in Los Angeles on May 26th 2001
at the age of 67 with the reported cause
of death being congestive heart failure
following her death a funeral service
was held in Pasadena Haney was survived
by her daughter sister and granddaughter
have a nice day in court actor Charles
rocket was responsible for portraying
the main villain and Dumb and Dumber
Nicholas Andre in the film the character
kidnapped Bobby Swanson and held him for
ransom although he was eventually foiled
by The Duo of har and Lloyd before his
role in the movie he was a cast member
of Saturday Night Live but was fired
after swearing live on air during an
episode later he had roles in Hocus
Pocus Dances with Wolves and Titan AE
rocket died on October 7th 201 5 his
body was discovered in a field near his
home in Connecticut he was found with
injuries to his neck and police letter
confirmed that he died by Suicide with
the coroner concluding that there were
no suspicious circumstances the only
film that featured both reggy Kathy and
Jim Carrey was the mask the actor
portrayed freeze a mobster and career
Criminal Who encounters Stanley iiss
when he attempts to rob a bank for his
boss Dorian Tyrell however he is
probably best known for his roles in the
television series The Wire Oz and House
of Cards the latter of which earned him
an Emmy Award nomination the actor also
portrayed Dr Franklin storm in the 2015
film Fantastic 4 the actor was just 59
when he died in his New York home on
February 9th 2018 no cause of death was
given when the announcement was made but
the guardian reported that Kathy had
been diagnosed with lung cancer
previously leaving open the possibility
that he had died as a result of the
disease due to his relatively young age
a regular collaborator with Tim Burton
Michael gof was cast as Bruce Wayne's
trusty Butler Alfred pennyworth and
Batman and reprised the role in the
three sequels that followed it was in
this role that he worked with Jim Carrey
in the 1995 film Batman Forever where
Carrey played the super villain known as
The Riddler he also appeared in Burton's
Sleepy Hollow and voice characters in
corpsebride and Alis in Wonderland along
with appearances in Doctor Who and The
Advengers gof died on March 17th 2011 at
the age of 94 reportedly the actor had
previously been ill for more than a year
but the exact cause of death was not
given his former Batman co-star Michael
Keaton paid tribute to gon X formerly
known as Twitter saying to Mick my
Butler my Confidant my friend my Alfred
I love you God bless can I persuade you
to take a sandwich with you sir actor
ran Howard only appeared in a single Jim
Carrey movie playing a who known as the
elderly timekeeper in the 2000 film How
the Grinch Stole Christmas the movie was
directed by his son Ron Howard and also
starred Taylor momson Christine baransky
and Jeffrey tamber he appeared in many
other movies throughout his career
including Mars Attacks A Beautiful Mind
and Cinderella Man along with roles in
television series such as Lamy and rest
of development Howard was survived by
many members of his family some of whom
are actually well-known entertainment
figures in their own right these include
his sons Ron and Clint Howard and
granddaughter Bryce dallis Howard
speaking to variety Ron and Clint
explained how their father had West Nile
Virus a disease that quite quickly made
him very ill he died of heart failure
brought on by the virus on November 25th
2017 at his home in Los Angeles at the
age of 89 like Michael goof Pat Hingle
has the distinction of appearing in four
Batman films in his career portraying
commissioner Jim Gordon from 1989 until
1997 as the leader of the Gotham City
Police Department he interacted with
Batman and fought against the Riddler
and Batman Forever outside of the DC
Comics franchise Hingle was known for
his roles in films such as the gauntlet
and Sudden Impact as well as supporting
Parts in Taladega kns the ballot of
Ricky Bobby and the quick and the dead
Hull's death was confirmed by the Emy
television Academy on January 3rd 2009
it was reported that he had died from
Milo dysplastic syndrome a type of blood
cancer that prevents blood cells from
developing properly his cousin Lin
Heritage revealed that the actor was
diagnosed with the disease 3 years
earlier and passed away at his home in
Carolina Beach in North Carolina Renee
Ober xois started alongside Jim Carrey
and Batman Forever playing the head
doctor of Arkham Asylum Dr Burton the
character interacts with the Riddler and
too faace in the movie as he attempts to
understand what has driven them to
become criminals his most famous role
undoubtedly came in Star Trek Deep Space
9 where he portrayed the changeling
character known as Odo who acted as the
chief of security for the space station
as a voice actor he lent his voice to
characters in The Little Mermaid and
Fallout New Vegas and was also an
accomplished actor on Broadway winning a
number of Tony Award nominations Ober
xois was diagnosed with lung cancer in
2018 with the disease spreading to his
brain the following year this led to
seizures and other serious symptoms
prompting the actor to pursue Medical
Aid in dying according to his wife
Judith Ober xenoa he died at his home
surrounded by his family after taking
legal prescription medication while
listening to music and looking over old
photographs has been screaming for hours
that he know knows the true identity of
Batman Robert Forester appeared with Jim
Carrey and Me Myself and Irene in 2000
as the police chief Colonel Partington
who is Charlie Bailey Gates's boss on
the force before that he had developed a
reputation for portraying action heroes
and police officers in banion medium
cool and the black hole one of the
defining moments of his career came in
1997 with Quenton Tarantino's Jackie
Brown where he received plot its first
performance with Pam Greer and an
Academy Award nomination for best
supporting actor this revitalized his
career and saw him cast in television
shows and films such as Breaking Bad
mahand drive and heroes Forster's final
screen roll came in the 2021 film grave
intentions although this was a postumus
release the actor died on October 11th
2019 from brain cancer after having been
diagnosed with a brain tumor several
months previously the actor was 78 at
the time of his death and was survived
by his partner Denise Grayson and his
four children along with his numerous
grandchildren Hal holber was part of the
cast of The Majestic portraying
Congressman Doyle who berates Jim
Carrey's character Peter Appleton during
his Congressional hearing outside of the
2001 movie he was best known for
portraying Mark Twain in a variety of
oneman shows and adaptations these
performances earned him a number of
awards including Emy and a Tony Award he
also had roles in All the President's
Men Hercules and Wall Street as well as
a significant part in the TV series
North and South hulber died on January
23rd 2021 at the age of 95 at his home
in Beverly Hills however the news of his
death was not revealed until a week
later no cause of death was provided but
it was revealed that he was buried
alongside his third wife Dixie Carter in
Tennessee Hook was survived by three
children from two previous marriages and
his grandchildren Richard Jenny was not
an actor by trade and was more generally
known for his work as a stand-up
comedian he first came to the Public's
attention when he appeared on the
tonight's show with Johnny Carson and
later on the tonight's show with Jay
Leno he had a number of HBO specials
including platypus man in 1993 and a big
steaming pile of me in 2005 and the mask
he starred as car's best friend Charles
sadly the actor and comedian died by
suicide on March 10th 2007 after his
partner Amy Murphy discovered his body
in the kitchen the corner reported that
Jenny had experienced mental health
issues including schizophrenia
throughout his life and had been
involuntarily hospitalized with severe
depression shortly before his death this
young man here just saved Our Life With
a Little Help from his friend in the
Majestic Martin landow played Harry
Trimble the character is the father of a
missing soldier who didn't return from
World War II but he believes that car's
Peter Appleton is actually his son Luke
the actor Rose to Fame by appearing in
the television shows Mission Impossible
in space 1999 before going on to a
successful movie career this saw him
cast in Woody Allen's crimes and
misdemeanors and take on the iconic role
of Ella legosi in the biographical drama
Edwood in 1994 landow also worked as an
acting coach with Jack Nicholson among
his clients landow died in July 15th
2017 at the age of 89 shortly after
being admitted to the Ronald Reagan UCLA
Medical Center the official cause of
death was hypo volic shock a condition
brought about by heart failure and
extensive internal bleeding Alice
drumond portrayed ryle's mother and Ace
Ventura Pet Detective Mrs Finkle
welcomes Ace into her home as he
investigates the missing footballer and
discovers Race's hatred of quarterback
Dan Marino before that she had appeared
in the 1984 comedy Ghostbusters as a
librarian in addition to being a Tony
Award nominated Broadway performer for
her work in the Chinese and Dr fish in
1970 germond went on to make appearances
in Law and Order Boston Legal friends aw
Awakenings and doubt among many other
films and television shows Drummond was
88 years old when she died on November
30th 2016 her friend and colleague June
Gable confirmed that Drummond had been
ill for 2 months after falling at her
home in New York injuries caused by the
accident eventually led to her death
several weeks later if you or anyone you
know is having suicidal thoughts please
call the National Suicide Prevention
Lifeline by dialing 988 or by calling 1
1800273 talk